الان من حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب المختص
في الشان الاسرائيلي اهلا بك معنا اذا
القناه 12ثانيه ع الاسرائيليه سيد ايهاب
تنقل ان هناك خلاف بين نتنياهو وجانت بعد
تقارير عن منع رئيسي الموساد والشباك من
حضور جلسه لمجلس الحرب في اي اطار تضع هذا
الخبر نعم تحيات استاذ عبد السلام ومساء
الخير طبعا بطبيعه الحال هنا يجب ان نتذكر
ان في نهايه المطاف هنالك الكثير
يعني اوافق مع ما اتى من نجوان قبل قليل
يعني هذا مجلس الحرب استثنائي بكل معنى
الكلمه الكثير من الخلافات تطفو على السطح
اكث اكثر فاكثر الى الاعلام بل اكثر من
ذلك تحديدا الان في ظل ضعف بنيامين
نتنياهو هذا الامر الذي يجب ان يخذ بعين
الاعتبار بنيامين نتنياهو دخل الى مجلس
الحرب هذا ضعيفا بالنقيض ع ما كان عليه ما
قبل السابع من اكتوبر ما قبل السابع من
اكتوبر استطاع ان يدير او يفتعل ازمه
ويديرها بطبيعه الحال ووضع جلنت في
الزاويه في اكثر من موضع اخرها كان في ال
30 من مارس على ما نذكر الان تحديدا ما
بعد السابع من اكتوبر الامور مختلفه
بنيامين نتنياهو ضعيف المحاكم تنهش بلحمه
يمنه ويسره كما نرى في الايام الاخيره
كذلك الاداره الامريكيه وضعته في اكثر من
موضع يعني منعزلا منفردا يرتمي الى احضان
سموتريتش وبينغ فير بعدما كذلك كان هنالك
تحركات تمرد في داخل الليكود بمفهوم كذا
وكا اخر ايي كوهن يخرج بتصريحات ضده
فبالتالي واضح جدا ان هذه كلها في نهايه
المطاف تعطي
وتبرز الحديث الانتخابي ما بعد هذه الحرب
في نهايه المطاف هنالك شخصيات يجب ان تحكم
في اسرائيل في نهايه المطاف من يمين نتنه
لن يكون ذلك هخف هل تعتقد ان الخلاف لانك
تحدثت بان جالنت يوف جالنت حتى لم يكن
يرغب في ان يكون في في الحكومه ايام ازمه
الازمه القضائيه ان اذكر لكنه بعد كما
ذكرت نجوان في في حاله الحرب يفترض ان
تختفي اصوات الخلاف والسؤال هنا لماذا
يرفض نتنياهو اعطاء الفرصه ل بيوف جالنت
للجلوس مع شخصيات في مستوى رئيس الموساد
ورئيس الشبك ما الذي يخشاه بنيامين
نتنياهو من يوف
جلان وان كانوا يتفقون في التكتيك في
نهايه المطاف على سبيل المثال ما جرى في
لبنان قبل يومين من اغتيال ان كانوا
يتفقون في هذا
التكتيك لكن في نهايه المطاف
الاستراتيجيات تختلف استراتيجيه بنيامين
نتنياهو ميكافيليه من الدرجه الاولى سر
البقاء هذا كل ما يهم بنيامين نتنياهو على
ما يبدو انه مستعد ان يدفع الغالي حتى فقط
من اجل ان يبقى في الحكم ويبتعد اكثر
فاكثر عن لجان التحقيق والمحاكم في نهايه
المطاف جلنت ل يعني لا يريد ان يقن اسمه
في اسم بنيامين نتنياهو بنيامين نتنياهو
كذلك موقفه بات يكون اكثر ضعفا في داخل
الليكود بات يكون القاع ض الشعبيه بدات
تختفي اكثر فاكثر فلهذا السبب هو غير معني
بان يقرن اسمه مع اسم بنيامين نتنياهو باي
شكل من الاشكال هو يريد ان يكون مستقلا
وهو يرى ان هنالك فرصه كما قال يعني اليوم
اذا استعمل تعبير شباك الزمني القصير نعم
هنالك شباك زمني قصير حتى في هذا المضمار
ليبرز
جلنت بسياساته برؤيته يعني يخرج اليوم
ويتحدث عن اليوم التالي في داخل القطاع
يعني هذا مشهد منفرد وربما حتى لا لا
يتوافق مع رؤيه بنيامين نتنياهو يتحدث انه
لن تكون هنالك سياده مدنيه اسرائيليه
عسكريه عفوا في داخل القطاع يعني تدير
القطاع مدنيا او او حتى هنالك تلميحات انه
لن يتواجد اسرائيليون مدنيا يعني بمفهوم
الاستيطان بمفهوم كذا او كاخر هذه النغمه
تتردد وتتوافق مع رؤيه الولايات المتحده
يجب ان نتذكر ان في نهايه المطاف الولايات
المتحده ما زالت تبحث عن الشريك التالي في
داخل الاداره في داخل اسرائيل نتنياهو بات
موقفه ضعيفا اكثر فاك اكثر الاباتشي
جيرالد فورد كل هذه الامور وضعت بنيمين
نتنياهو بالزاويه حتى خرج وقال ان اعاده
المواطنون الى غلاف غزه او الى الجبهه
الشماليه منوط باما تحرك دبلوماسي او
عسكري يعني هذا حتى هنالك تليين بموقفه
اصلا الامريكيه لم نشهده من قبل عن رؤيه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه للوضع في قطاع
غزه وبا بالامس كان هناك تقييم جديد لجون
كربي كان لافتا تحدث عن بقاء حماس وانه لا
يمكن القضاء على فكر وايديولوجية
وبان لديها قدرات عسكريه وعليهم ان
يتقبلوا بقاء حماس وهنا عند هذه النقطه من
سيتقبل في داخل اسرائيل هذه الافكار
الامريكيه لاحظ ان جلنت كال لم نرضى بقبول
جهات عدوانيه ازاء اسرائيل في داخل القطاع
يعني هو كذلك هنالك هو يحاول ان يتوافق مع
هذا المضمار في الجانب الاول الجيش قالها
في اكثر من موقف انه اذا امرنا مستوى
السياسي ان نخرج من القطاع سوف نفعل ذلك
اي هو بتلميحات اخرى يقول لا يوجد لنا
ناقصا ولا بعير عسكريا في داخل الاهداف في
داخل القطاع كذلك يجب ان نتذكر ان في خضم
هذه المرحله سوتيش وبينغ فير يحاولون
احتكار الاهداف السياسيه للقطاع التهجير
والاستيطان واعاده الاستيطان هذا الامر لا
يريده الجيش بالمناسبه باي شكل من الاشكال
كما لا تريده الولايات المتحده بمفهوم كذا
او كاخر الجيش لا يريد ان يقوم باعمال
شرطيه او حراس
ميه المستوطنين ولا جيش شرطي ازاء
الفلسطينيين كما يقوم به في داخل الضفه
الغربيه اصلا هذا المورد يجب بجمله صغيره
وقصيره هذا المورد ضرب كثيرا وفق ما جاء
بحك بريك بقدرات الجيش في السنوات الاخيره
اصلا ايهاب جبار الكاتب المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي من حيفا شكرا جزيلا لك